[Music]
it comes with an intel i9 processor
nvidia rtx 2060 gpu
a 4k oled touchscreen display
and wi-fi 6 connectivity
they call it
the laptop of tomorrow
what's up everybody zaki here from geek
culture and this is the geek's guide to
the asus zenbook pro duo
the asus zenbook pro duo packs in a lot
of features including an additional
multi-touch display also known as the
screen pad plus
designed to give you better workflow and
productivity be it a budding
photographer a powerhouse video editor a
writer an illustrator or a video game
streamer there's something in it for
everyone featuring a full-width 14.1
inch 4k display the same book pro duals
screen pad plus comes with multiple
features and built-in apps that work
seamlessly with the 15.6 inch 4k ultra
hd oled display main screen
though new this second screen might just
be the mainstay of asus's future
offerings
so let's dive in and explore all the
cool things you can do with the asus
zenbook pro duo and the screen pad plus
the organizer app taps on the screenpad
pluses extra real estate you can arrange
up to three blocks of apps by simply
dragging them onto the screenpad plus it
will then resize these windows and snap
them into place for your convenience
the task group is an amazing app which
lets you customize and run multiple apps
with just one tab
you can open up to 5 apps all windows 2
on the main screen and 3 smaller ones on
the screen pad plus
so if you prefer to multitask and need
all your apps up and running task group
on the screenpad plus is the perfect
solution
viewmax is an amazing way to fully
utilize the zenbook pro duo
this effectively combines the screen pad
plus and the main display into one big
screen
it's perfect for reading your daily news
or just surfing the net in general
with so much on screen how do you
navigate through them all
app navigator makes everything easy
breezy
you can easily view all your apps at
once and close apps you don't need
without even accessing them
if you're a frequent user of editing
software
the zenbook pro duo has the quick keys
function
such as copy paste and undo
that you can use to speed up your
editing process
here's something you might forget when
using the zenbook pro duo the number pad
can be activated by simply tapping on
this on-screen button here
and finally if you have the handwriting
function which when coupled with the
zenbook pro duo's asus pen helps to turn
your handwriting into text
great for lazy periods where a keyboard
just won't do
with the screen pad plus you will also
no longer need an external tablet to
doodle on as you can simply use the asus
pen to sketch and doodle straight onto
the screen pad plus
well here are just some of the nifty
special features of the asus zenbook pro
duo if you'd like to see our review of
the asus zenbook pro duo you can check
out the link in the description below
if you enjoyed this video give it a
thumbs up subscribe and click on the
notification bell icon to stay updated
with more geeky news and tidbits
until then this is zeki and stay geeky
[Music]